monfort majesté vous êtes rendu compte à
quel âge que vous ressembliez autant à
elizabeth 2 ghz et c'est arrivé très
très très très jeune j'avais 13 ans et
la princesse à l'époque en avait 17 sa
photo est pas et est apparu dans les
journaux en france parce qu'elle se
fiancer avec le liban de battles et
toutes mes camarades de classe m'ont
sauté dessus et ça a commencé comme ça
et c'est vrai que la duchesse de bedford
quand elle vous a vu à l'olympia elle a
failli attraper une crise cardiaque en
le découvrant
je n'ai pas trébucher m'enfin ce cri
d'étonnement ma belle surprise et déçue
par la suite que la belle affiche du 7
septembre devrait avec rue ou sur le
moment que
mes trois mois vous devez avoir beaucoup
de succès avec les hommes majesté n'ont
que pour eux quand même c'est
extraordinaire de pouvoir courtisé la
reine d'angleterre à quand la reine
d'angleterre mais je suis la france
hélas mes choix pour julien le soir pour
eux
est-ce que livrent les hommes vous
appelle marraine marraine nom ne vous
est jamais arrivé à niamey arrivé dans
ce machin qu'est ce que je leur souffle
dans la rangée à la télé là maintenant
ils le savent pas merci et garonne froc
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu